I I GOT SO MUCH OUT OF IT. AND IT‘S SO CLEAR THAT THE
GOT SO MUCH OUT OF IT. AND IT‘S SO CLEAR THAT THE REPUBLICANS, THEY HAVE A
AND IT‘S SO CLEAR THAT THE REPUBLICANS, THEY HAVE A STRATEGY AND
REPUBLICANS, THEY HAVE A STRATEGY AND THEY‘RE EXECUTING THEIR
STRATEGY AND THEY‘RE EXECUTING THEIR STRATEGY. IT IS
THEY‘RE EXECUTING THEIR STRATEGY. IT IS SUPPRESSING. THE VOTES OF
STRATEGY. IT IS SUPPRESSING. THE VOTES OF VOTERS
SUPPRESSING. THE VOTES OF VOTERS OF COLOR AND YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
VOTERS OF COLOR AND YOUNG PEOPLE WHO TURNED OUT FOR JOE, BIDEN AND
OF COLOR AND YOUNG PEOPLE WHO TURNED OUT FOR JOE, BIDEN AND FLIP, GEORGIA, AND ARIZONA.
TURNED OUT FOR JOE, BIDEN AND FLIP, GEORGIA, AND ARIZONA. AND
FLIP, GEORGIA, AND ARIZONA. AND WHO, ACCORDING TO DATA,
AND WHO, ACCORDING TO DATA, LESS LIKELY TO VOTE FOR
WHO, ACCORDING TO DATA, LESS LIKELY TO VOTE FOR REPUBLICANS.
LESS LIKELY TO VOTE FOR REPUBLICANS. SO
REPUBLICANS. SO WHAT‘S THE DEMOCRATS
SO WHAT‘S THE DEMOCRATS STRATEGY?
WHAT‘S THE DEMOCRATS STRATEGY? LOOK, WE BELIEVE IN FIGHTING
STRATEGY? LOOK, WE BELIEVE IN FIGHTING FAIR
LOOK, WE BELIEVE IN FIGHTING FAIR AND HAVING LAWS IN PLACE
FAIR AND HAVING LAWS IN PLACE THAT MAKE IT EASIER
AND HAVING LAWS IN PLACE THAT MAKE IT EASIER FOR PEOPLE TO VOTE
THAT MAKE IT EASIER FOR PEOPLE TO VOTE RIGHT THROUGH. AND THAT‘S THE
FOR PEOPLE TO VOTE RIGHT THROUGH. AND THAT‘S THE WHOLE POINT OF A DEMOCRACY,
RIGHT THROUGH. AND THAT‘S THE WHOLE POINT OF A DEMOCRACY, NOT TO THINK. WELL THE ONLY
WHOLE POINT OF A DEMOCRACY, NOT TO THINK. WELL THE ONLY WAY I CAN WIN
NOT TO THINK. WELL THE ONLY WAY I CAN WIN IS IF I CAN
WAY I CAN WIN IS IF I CAN SUPPRESS IN WAYS THAT ARE
IS IF I CAN SUPPRESS IN WAYS THAT ARE INCONSISTENT WITH THE CORE
SUPPRESS IN WAYS THAT ARE INCONSISTENT WITH THE CORE VALUES OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
INCONSISTENT WITH THE CORE VALUES OF OUR DEMOCRACY. YOU‘RE RIGHT TO VOTE. AND
VALUES OF OUR DEMOCRACY. YOU‘RE RIGHT TO VOTE. AND YOU‘RE RIGHT IN A VERY
YOU‘RE RIGHT TO VOTE. AND YOU‘RE RIGHT IN A VERY DIABOLICAL WAY,
YOU‘RE RIGHT IN A VERY DIABOLICAL WAY, PARTICULARLY ACROSS THE SOUTH
DIABOLICAL WAY, PARTICULARLY ACROSS THE SOUTH WE ARE SEEING INCREASING
PARTICULARLY ACROSS THE SOUTH WE ARE SEEING INCREASING NUMBERS OF LEGISLATORS
WE ARE SEEING INCREASING NUMBERS OF LEGISLATORS WHO DID NOT LIKE THE OUTCOME
NUMBERS OF LEGISLATORS WHO DID NOT LIKE THE OUTCOME OF THE
WHO DID NOT LIKE THE OUTCOME OF THE ELECTION. WHICH
OF THE ELECTION. WHICH WAS FAIR AND SQUARE.
ELECTION. WHICH WAS FAIR AND SQUARE. DON‘T LISTEN TO ME. LISTEN, TO
WAS FAIR AND SQUARE. DON‘T LISTEN TO ME. LISTEN, TO PRESIDENT. TRUMP‘S
DON‘T LISTEN TO ME. LISTEN, TO PRESIDENT. TRUMP‘S FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL. WHO
PRESIDENT. TRUMP‘S FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL. WHO SAID IT WAS ALL NONSENSE TO
FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL. WHO SAID IT WAS ALL NONSENSE TO THINK THAT THE ELECTION WASN‘T
SAID IT WAS ALL NONSENSE TO THINK THAT THE ELECTION WASN‘T ON THE UP-AND-UP.
THINK THAT THE ELECTION WASN‘T ON THE UP-AND-UP. SO THEY SAY OKAY, WELL IF WE
ON THE UP-AND-UP. SO THEY SAY OKAY, WELL IF WE CAN‘T WIN FAIR AND SQUARE,
SO THEY SAY OKAY, WELL IF WE CAN‘T WIN FAIR AND SQUARE, LET‘S SEE WHAT WE CAN DO
CAN‘T WIN FAIR AND SQUARE, LET‘S SEE WHAT WE CAN DO TO SUPPRESS THE VOTE.
LET‘S SEE WHAT WE CAN DO TO SUPPRESS THE VOTE. THERE ARE 48 STATES
TO SUPPRESS THE VOTE. THERE ARE 48 STATES WHERE REPUBLICANS IN
THERE ARE 48 STATES WHERE REPUBLICANS IN THEIR LEGISLATORS ARE TRYING
WHERE REPUBLICANS IN THEIR LEGISLATORS ARE TRYING TO MAKE IT HARDER TO VOTE
THEIR LEGISLATORS ARE TRYING TO MAKE IT HARDER TO VOTE IN THE ABSENCE OF VOTE FRAUD.
TO MAKE IT HARDER TO VOTE IN THE ABSENCE OF VOTE FRAUD. AND IT IS CLEARLY AN
IN THE ABSENCE OF VOTE FRAUD. AND IT IS CLEARLY AN INTENT TO
AND IT IS CLEARLY AN INTENT TO DISCOURAGE BLACK AND BROWN
INTENT TO DISCOURAGE BLACK AND BROWN FEED PEOPLE FROM BEING ABLE TO
DISCOURAGE BLACK AND BROWN FEED PEOPLE FROM BEING ABLE TO VOTE AND YOUNG.
FEED PEOPLE FROM BEING ABLE TO VOTE AND YOUNG. PEOPLE TOO, FOR THAT MATTER.
VOTE AND YOUNG. PEOPLE TOO, FOR THAT MATTER. AND THE ONLY THING THAT STANDS
PEOPLE TOO, FOR THAT MATTER. AND THE ONLY THING THAT STANDS IN THE WAY OF THAT HAPPENING,
AND THE ONLY THING THAT STANDS IN THE WAY OF THAT HAPPENING, IS US
IN THE WAY OF THAT HAPPENING, IS US THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, WHICH IS
IS US THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, WHICH IS WHY WE HAVE TO SPEAK OUT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, WHICH IS WHY WE HAVE TO SPEAK OUT LOUD AND CLEARLY ON THIS
WHY WE HAVE TO SPEAK OUT LOUD AND CLEARLY ON THIS ISSUE.
LOUD AND CLEARLY ON THIS ISSUE. VOTING RIGHTS WAS A CRITICAL
ISSUE. VOTING RIGHTS WAS A CRITICAL ISSUE, GOING BACK TO 2013
VOTING RIGHTS WAS A CRITICAL ISSUE, GOING BACK TO 2013 WHEN THE SHELBY DECISION
ISSUE, GOING BACK TO 2013 WHEN THE SHELBY DECISION HAPPENED AND THAT WAS DURING
WHEN THE SHELBY DECISION HAPPENED AND THAT WAS DURING THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
HAPPENED AND THAT WAS DURING THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION. CAN YOU TALK ABOUT THE WAYS
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION. CAN YOU TALK ABOUT THE WAYS ATTORNEY GENERAL ERIC HOLDER,
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT THE WAYS ATTORNEY GENERAL ERIC HOLDER, WHO WAS INCLUDED IN THAT
ATTORNEY GENERAL ERIC HOLDER, WHO WAS INCLUDED IN THAT CONVERSATION? THE WAYS, A G
WHO WAS INCLUDED IN THAT CONVERSATION? THE WAYS, A G HOLDER AND YOUR ADMINISTRATION
CONVERSATION? THE WAYS, A G HOLDER AND YOUR ADMINISTRATION IN PARTICULAR WORK TO PROTECT
HOLDER AND YOUR ADMINISTRATION IN PARTICULAR WORK TO PROTECT VOTING RIGHTS. BECAUSE AS
IN PARTICULAR WORK TO PROTECT VOTING RIGHTS. BECAUSE AS SOON AS THAT SHE‘LL BE
VOTING RIGHTS. BECAUSE AS SOON AS THAT SHE‘LL BE DECISION WAS HANDED DOWN THE
SOON AS THAT SHE‘LL BE DECISION WAS HANDED DOWN THE DOJ,
DECISION WAS HANDED DOWN THE DOJ, THEY WENT TO WORK.
DOJ, THEY WENT TO WORK. WHAT DID THEY DO?
THEY WENT TO WORK. WHAT DID THEY DO? BUT WE TRIED VERY HARD
WHAT DID THEY DO? BUT WE TRIED VERY HARD STATE-BY-STATE TO TRY TO
BUT WE TRIED VERY HARD STATE-BY-STATE TO TRY TO PROTECT
STATE-BY-STATE TO TRY TO PROTECT THE
PROTECT THE THE ABILITY FOR
THE THE ABILITY FOR LOCAL
THE ABILITY FOR LOCAL FOLKS WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
LOCAL FOLKS WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE ELECTIONS TO HAVE FAIR AND
FOLKS WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE ELECTIONS TO HAVE FAIR AND OPEN ELECTIONS
THE ELECTIONS TO HAVE FAIR AND OPEN ELECTIONS AND THAT WAS MUCH HARDER AFTER
OPEN ELECTIONS AND THAT WAS MUCH HARDER AFTER SHELBY SHELBY
AND THAT WAS MUCH HARDER AFTER SHELBY SHELBY REQUIRED, THE BURDEN OF PROOF
SHELBY SHELBY REQUIRED, THE BURDEN OF PROOF TO BE ON THEM TO SAY, OKAY, WE
REQUIRED, THE BURDEN OF PROOF TO BE ON THEM TO SAY, OKAY, WE ARE OPERATING A FAIR ELECTION.
TO BE ON THEM TO SAY, OKAY, WE ARE OPERATING A FAIR ELECTION. IT‘S SHIFTED. WHEN THAT
ARE OPERATING A FAIR ELECTION. IT‘S SHIFTED. WHEN THAT PROTECTION WAS GUTTED FROM THE
IT‘S SHIFTED. WHEN THAT PROTECTION WAS GUTTED FROM THE VOTING RIGHTS ACT, AND WE
PROTECTION WAS GUTTED FROM THE VOTING RIGHTS ACT, AND WE TRIED TO GET CONGRESS.
VOTING RIGHTS ACT, AND WE TRIED TO GET CONGRESS. THE REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS TO
TRIED TO GET CONGRESS. THE REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS TO BE SPECIFIC TO
THE REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS TO BE SPECIFIC TO REAUTHORIZE IT BECAUSE OF WHAT
BE SPECIFIC TO REAUTHORIZE IT BECAUSE OF WHAT THE SUPREME COURT.
REAUTHORIZE IT BECAUSE OF WHAT THE SUPREME COURT. SAID IS WE‘RE NOT GOING TO
THE SUPREME COURT. SAID IS WE‘RE NOT GOING TO UPHOLD IT BUT GO BACK TO
SAID IS WE‘RE NOT GOING TO UPHOLD IT BUT GO BACK TO CONGRESS. THAT‘S YOUR REMEDY
UPHOLD IT BUT GO BACK TO CONGRESS. THAT‘S YOUR REMEDY AND GET THEM TO DO SO.
CONGRESS. THAT‘S YOUR REMEDY AND GET THEM TO DO SO. AND THE FACT THAT SINCE THAT
AND GET THEM TO DO SO. AND THE FACT THAT SINCE THAT TIME,
AND THE FACT THAT SINCE THAT TIME, NOT ONLY HAVE THE REPUBLICANS
TIME, NOT ONLY HAVE THE REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS,
NOT ONLY HAVE THE REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS, NOT MOVE FORWARD WITH A
IN CONGRESS, NOT MOVE FORWARD WITH A REAUTHORIZATION.
NOT MOVE FORWARD WITH A REAUTHORIZATION. BUT AS I SAID,
REAUTHORIZATION. BUT AS I SAID, STATE-BY-STATE, THEY HAVE BEEN
BUT AS I SAID, STATE-BY-STATE, THEY HAVE BEEN TRYING TO PASS LAWS TO
STATE-BY-STATE, THEY HAVE BEEN TRYING TO PASS LAWS TO SUPPRESS THE VOTE AND ON TOP
TRYING TO PASS LAWS TO SUPPRESS THE VOTE AND ON TOP OF THAT,
SUPPRESS THE VOTE AND ON TOP OF THAT, THEY ARE GIVING VOICE
OF THAT, THEY ARE GIVING VOICE TO THE
THEY ARE GIVING VOICE TO THE NONSENSE. THEY‘RE TRYING TO
TO THE NONSENSE. THEY‘RE TRYING TO BAMBOOZLE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
NONSENSE. THEY‘RE TRYING TO BAMBOOZLE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE INTO THINKING
BAMBOOZLE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE INTO THINKING THAT THERE WAS
INTO THINKING THAT THERE WAS SOMETHING
THAT THERE WAS SOMETHING SOMETHING UNFAIR.
SOMETHING SOMETHING UNFAIR. ARE ABOUT THE LAST ELECTION
SOMETHING UNFAIR. ARE ABOUT THE LAST ELECTION AND THAT IS HARMFUL FOR
ARE ABOUT THE LAST ELECTION AND THAT IS HARMFUL FOR TOWARD DEMOCRACY, NO MATTER
AND THAT IS HARMFUL FOR TOWARD DEMOCRACY, NO MATTER WHO‘S IN OFFICE,
TOWARD DEMOCRACY, NO MATTER WHO‘S IN OFFICE, WE HOLD OURSELVES OUT,
WHO‘S IN OFFICE, WE HOLD OURSELVES OUT, SAILING AROUND THE WORLD
WE HOLD OURSELVES OUT, SAILING AROUND THE WORLD AS A COUNTRY THAT HAS A STRONG
SAILING AROUND THE WORLD AS A COUNTRY THAT HAS A STRONG DEMOCRACY.
AS A COUNTRY THAT HAS A STRONG DEMOCRACY. AND SO, IF WE ARE SUPPORTING
DEMOCRACY. AND SO, IF WE ARE SUPPORTING INSURRECTIONS AND SAYING THAT
AND SO, IF WE ARE SUPPORTING INSURRECTIONS AND SAYING THAT THEY‘RE JUST LIKE YOUR AVERAGE
INSURRECTIONS AND SAYING THAT THEY‘RE JUST LIKE YOUR AVERAGE TOUR OF THE CAPITOL,
THEY‘RE JUST LIKE YOUR AVERAGE TOUR OF THE CAPITOL, AND WE ARE CONDONING THOSE
TOUR OF THE CAPITOL, AND WE ARE CONDONING THOSE WHO QUESTION THE ELECTION
AND WE ARE CONDONING THOSE WHO QUESTION THE ELECTION THOSE WHO CRITICIZE THE VICE
WHO QUESTION THE ELECTION THOSE WHO CRITICIZE THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
THOSE WHO CRITICIZE THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES. FOR CERTIFYING THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES. FOR CERTIFYING THE ELECTION, SOMETHING HE JUST
STATES. FOR CERTIFYING THE ELECTION, SOMETHING HE JUST SPOKE OUT AND SAID HE HAD NO
ELECTION, SOMETHING HE JUST SPOKE OUT AND SAID HE HAD NO CHOICE
SPOKE OUT AND SAID HE HAD NO CHOICE TO DO.
CHOICE TO DO. THEN WE ARE IN TROUBLE. AND SO
TO DO. THEN WE ARE IN TROUBLE. AND SO YES, DURING PRESIDENT OBAMA‘S
THEN WE ARE IN TROUBLE. AND SO YES, DURING PRESIDENT OBAMA‘S TIME IN OFFICE,
YES, DURING PRESIDENT OBAMA‘S TIME IN OFFICE, ERIC HOLDER WAS A LEADER IN
TIME IN OFFICE, ERIC HOLDER WAS A LEADER IN THIS EFFORT,
ERIC HOLDER WAS A LEADER IN THIS EFFORT, TRYING TO ENSURE THAT HE
THIS EFFORT, TRYING TO ENSURE THAT HE PROTECTED THE RIGHTS OF
TRYING TO ENSURE THAT HE PROTECTED THE RIGHTS OF CITIZENS AND I‘M HEARTENED TO
PROTECTED THE RIGHTS OF CITIZENS AND I‘M HEARTENED TO SAY THAT ME REGARD
CITIZENS AND I‘M HEARTENED TO SAY THAT ME REGARD GARLAND. THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
SAY THAT ME REGARD GARLAND. THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TODAY IS
GARLAND. THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TODAY IS HAS FILED A LAWSUIT
TODAY IS HAS FILED A LAWSUIT AGAINST THE STATE OF GEORGIA
HAS FILED A LAWSUIT AGAINST THE STATE OF GEORGIA AND SAYING THAT THE LAWS THAT
AGAINST THE STATE OF GEORGIA AND SAYING THAT THE LAWS THAT THEY PASSED
AND SAYING THAT THE LAWS THAT THEY PASSED ARE UNCONSTITUTIONAL
THEY PASSED ARE UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND THAT‘S WHAT WE ARE GOING
ARE UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND THAT‘S WHAT WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO DO
AND THAT‘S WHAT WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO DO STATE BY STATE BY STATE.
TO HAVE TO DO STATE BY STATE BY STATE. BUT I ALSO
STATE BY STATE BY STATE. BUT I ALSO WANT TO JUST SAY, LET‘S
BUT I ALSO WANT TO JUST SAY, LET‘S IT‘S NOT LEAVE IT TO THE
WANT TO JUST SAY, LET‘S IT‘S NOT LEAVE IT TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL‘S TO FIGHT
IT‘S NOT LEAVE IT TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL‘S TO FIGHT ON OUR BEHALF.
ATTORNEY GENERAL‘S TO FIGHT ON OUR BEHALF. WE HAVE TO ADD OUR VOICES TO
ON OUR BEHALF. WE HAVE TO ADD OUR VOICES TO THE EQUATION, AND WE HAVE
WE HAVE TO ADD OUR VOICES TO THE EQUATION, AND WE HAVE TO VOTE OUT OF OFFICE
THE EQUATION, AND WE HAVE TO VOTE OUT OF OFFICE PEOPLE, WHO ARE DOING THESE
TO VOTE OUT OF OFFICE PEOPLE, WHO ARE DOING THESE DASTARDLY DEEDS,
PEOPLE, WHO ARE DOING THESE DASTARDLY DEEDS, IT FEELS LIKE AND THE WORD
DASTARDLY DEEDS, IT FEELS LIKE AND THE WORD BAMBOOZLED IS UNDER
IT FEELS LIKE AND THE WORD BAMBOOZLED IS UNDER UNDERUTILIZED. FRANKLY, I
BAMBOOZLED IS UNDER UNDERUTILIZED. FRANKLY, I THINK
UNDERUTILIZED. FRANKLY, I THINK IT IS A VERY GOOD WORD AND
THINK IT IS A VERY GOOD WORD AND I FEEL LIKE IN A LOT OF WAYS
IT IS A VERY GOOD WORD AND I FEEL LIKE IN A LOT OF WAYS YOU KNOW WHEN
I FEEL LIKE IN A LOT OF WAYS YOU KNOW WHEN YOU WHEN YOU PUT IT THAT WAY
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU WHEN YOU PUT IT THAT WAY IT JUST
YOU WHEN YOU PUT IT THAT WAY IT JUST IT‘S SO APPLICABLE HERE
IT JUST IT‘S SO APPLICABLE HERE BECAUSE
IT‘S SO APPLICABLE HERE BECAUSE WE ALL WANT A DEMOCRACY. LIKE
BECAUSE WE ALL WANT A DEMOCRACY. LIKE I DON‘T CARE WHAT SIDE OF THE
WE ALL WANT A DEMOCRACY. LIKE I DON‘T CARE WHAT SIDE OF THE POLITICAL AISLE YOU‘RE ON OR
I DON‘T CARE WHAT SIDE OF THE POLITICAL AISLE YOU‘RE ON OR WHAT YOU CARE ABOUT IN TERMS
POLITICAL AISLE YOU‘RE ON OR WHAT YOU CARE ABOUT IN TERMS OF TAX CUTS, LIKE WHAT THE
WHAT YOU CARE ABOUT IN TERMS OF TAX CUTS, LIKE WHAT THE TAX RATE YOU PREFER IS,
OF TAX CUTS, LIKE WHAT THE TAX RATE YOU PREFER IS, THAT‘S NOT THE POINT. THE
TAX RATE YOU PREFER IS, THAT‘S NOT THE POINT. THE POINT IS, IS THAT YOU WANT IT
THAT‘S NOT THE POINT. THE POINT IS, IS THAT YOU WANT IT TO BE FAIR FOR EVERYBODY.
POINT IS, IS THAT YOU WANT IT TO BE FAIR FOR EVERYBODY. AND SO
TO BE FAIR FOR EVERYBODY. AND SO MANY OF THESE
AND SO MANY OF THESE LAWS ARE GOING INTO PLACE
MANY OF THESE LAWS ARE GOING INTO PLACE AND THEY‘RE ALREADY IN PLACE.
LAWS ARE GOING INTO PLACE AND THEY‘RE ALREADY IN PLACE. SO AT THIS POINT, IT‘S A
AND THEY‘RE ALREADY IN PLACE. SO AT THIS POINT, IT‘S A LITTLE BIT ABOUT MITIGATING
SO AT THIS POINT, IT‘S A LITTLE BIT ABOUT MITIGATING THE DAMAGE.
LITTLE BIT ABOUT MITIGATING THE DAMAGE. WHAT ARE SOME OF THE WAYS THAT
THE DAMAGE. WHAT ARE SOME OF THE WAYS THAT CAN BE DONE? IS IT,
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE WAYS THAT CAN BE DONE? IS IT, IS IT JUST THE
CAN BE DONE? IS IT, IS IT JUST THE VOTERS AT HOME CALLING
IS IT JUST THE VOTERS AT HOME CALLING CONGRESS UNTIL
VOTERS AT HOME CALLING CONGRESS UNTIL THEY FINALLY PICK
CONGRESS UNTIL THEY FINALLY PICK UP TO ENSURE THAT
THEY FINALLY PICK UP TO ENSURE THAT THERE‘S FEDERAL LEGISLATION AS
UP TO ENSURE THAT THERE‘S FEDERAL LEGISLATION AS SOON AS POSSIBLE OR ARE THERE
THERE‘S FEDERAL LEGISLATION AS SOON AS POSSIBLE OR ARE THERE OTHER THINGS THAT
SOON AS POSSIBLE OR ARE THERE OTHER THINGS THAT BIDEN CAN DO?
OTHER THINGS THAT BIDEN CAN DO? WELL, AS WE SPOKE HIS
BIDEN CAN DO? WELL, AS WE SPOKE HIS ATTORNEY GENERAL ON HIS OWN
WELL, AS WE SPOKE HIS ATTORNEY GENERAL ON HIS OWN INDEPENDENTLY
ATTORNEY GENERAL ON HIS OWN INDEPENDENTLY IS CHALLENGING LAWS
INDEPENDENTLY IS CHALLENGING LAWS ON THE BASIS OF THEM BEING
IS CHALLENGING LAWS ON THE BASIS OF THEM BEING UNCONSTITUTIONAL
ON THE BASIS OF THEM BEING UNCONSTITUTIONAL INCONSISTENT WITH THE VOTING
UNCONSTITUTIONAL INCONSISTENT WITH THE VOTING RIGHTS ACT.
INCONSISTENT WITH THE VOTING RIGHTS ACT. THOSE LAWS THAT ARE
RIGHTS ACT. THOSE LAWS THAT ARE SUPPRESSING THE VOTE LOOK
THOSE LAWS THAT ARE SUPPRESSING THE VOTE LOOK JUST TAKE GEORGIA, THEY‘RE
SUPPRESSING THE VOTE LOOK JUST TAKE GEORGIA, THEY‘RE MAKING IT HARDER FOR PEOPLE TO
JUST TAKE GEORGIA, THEY‘RE MAKING IT HARDER FOR PEOPLE TO VOTE ABSENTEE.
MAKING IT HARDER FOR PEOPLE TO VOTE ABSENTEE. THEY‘RE SAYING, IT‘S A CRIME,
VOTE ABSENTEE. THEY‘RE SAYING, IT‘S A CRIME, IF YOU TAKE FOOD OR DRINKS
THEY‘RE SAYING, IT‘S A CRIME, IF YOU TAKE FOOD OR DRINKS TO SOMEBODY WHO‘S STANDING
IF YOU TAKE FOOD OR DRINKS TO SOMEBODY WHO‘S STANDING LINE. COME ON NOW
TO SOMEBODY WHO‘S STANDING LINE. COME ON NOW WE‘RE STANDING IN LINE. YOU
LINE. COME ON NOW WE‘RE STANDING IN LINE. YOU DON‘T THINK THAT SOMEBODY
WE‘RE STANDING IN LINE. YOU DON‘T THINK THAT SOMEBODY SHOULD BE ABLE TO BRING US
DON‘T THINK THAT SOMEBODY SHOULD BE ABLE TO BRING US FOOD OR WATER PARTICULARLY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO BRING US FOOD OR WATER PARTICULARLY IN A STATE WHERE
FOOD OR WATER PARTICULARLY IN A STATE WHERE WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE LONG
IN A STATE WHERE WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE LONG LINES AND PEOPLE HAVE TO WAIT
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE LONG LINES AND PEOPLE HAVE TO WAIT FOR HOURS TO VOTE.
LINES AND PEOPLE HAVE TO WAIT FOR HOURS TO VOTE. AND SO WE NEED OUR JUSTICE
FOR HOURS TO VOTE. AND SO WE NEED OUR JUSTICE DEPARTMENT DOING EXACTLY WHAT
AND SO WE NEED OUR JUSTICE DEPARTMENT DOING EXACTLY WHAT ATTORNEY GENERAL MERKON IS
DEPARTMENT DOING EXACTLY WHAT ATTORNEY GENERAL MERKON IS DOING. WE NEED TO HAVE PEOPLE
ATTORNEY GENERAL MERKON IS DOING. WE NEED TO HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE VOTING AND SHOWING UP
DOING. WE NEED TO HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE VOTING AND SHOWING UP AT THE POLLS IN RECORD
WHO ARE VOTING AND SHOWING UP AT THE POLLS IN RECORD NUMBERS
AT THE POLLS IN RECORD NUMBERS AND SO
NUMBERS AND SO IF I‘M OUT THERE AND I‘M
AND SO IF I‘M OUT THERE AND I‘M HEARING THIS STORY THAT
IF I‘M OUT THERE AND I‘M HEARING THIS STORY THAT SOMEBODY IS TRYING TO
HEARING THIS STORY THAT SOMEBODY IS TRYING TO BAMBOOZLE ME AND TELL ME THAT
SOMEBODY IS TRYING TO BAMBOOZLE ME AND TELL ME THAT THE ELECTION IS UNFAIR,
BAMBOOZLE ME AND TELL ME THAT THE ELECTION IS UNFAIR, AND I KNOW THAT THAT‘S NOT
THE ELECTION IS UNFAIR, AND I KNOW THAT THAT‘S NOT TRUE AND I KNOW THAT THEY‘RE
AND I KNOW THAT THAT‘S NOT TRUE AND I KNOW THAT THEY‘RE TRYING TO SUPPRESS MY VOTE.
TRUE AND I KNOW THAT THEY‘RE TRYING TO SUPPRESS MY VOTE. I‘M GOING TO STAND IN LINE AND
TRYING TO SUPPRESS MY VOTE. I‘M GOING TO STAND IN LINE AND BE EVEN MORE DETERMINED TO
I‘M GOING TO STAND IN LINE AND BE EVEN MORE DETERMINED TO VOTE
BE EVEN MORE DETERMINED TO VOTE I‘M
VOTE I‘M TO SHOW UP AND MAKE SURE MY
I‘M TO SHOW UP AND MAKE SURE MY VOTE COUNTS BECAUSE
TO SHOW UP AND MAKE SURE MY VOTE COUNTS BECAUSE I KNOW THAT I STAND ON THE
VOTE COUNTS BECAUSE I KNOW THAT I STAND ON THE SHOULDERS OF PEOPLE WHO FOUGHT
I KNOW THAT I STAND ON THE SHOULDERS OF PEOPLE WHO FOUGHT AND SACRIFICED
SHOULDERS OF PEOPLE WHO FOUGHT AND SACRIFICED GREATLY
AND SACRIFICED GREATLY FOR ME TO HAVE THAT RIGHT TO
GREATLY FOR ME TO HAVE THAT RIGHT TO VOTE.
FOR ME TO HAVE THAT RIGHT TO VOTE. I‘M NOT GONNA LET ANY
VOTE. I‘M NOT GONNA LET ANY LEGISLATOR. TAKE IT AWAY FROM
I‘M NOT GONNA LET ANY LEGISLATOR. TAKE IT AWAY FROM ME SO WE SHOULD BE
LEGISLATOR. TAKE IT AWAY FROM ME SO WE SHOULD BE OUTRAGED AND WE SHOULD BE MORE
ME SO WE SHOULD BE OUTRAGED AND WE SHOULD BE MORE DETERMINED THAN EVER NO MATTER
OUTRAGED AND WE SHOULD BE MORE DETERMINED THAN EVER NO MATTER WHAT OBSTACLES, THEY PUT IN
DETERMINED THAN EVER NO MATTER WHAT OBSTACLES, THEY PUT IN OUR WAY
WHAT OBSTACLES, THEY PUT IN OUR WAY TO SHOW UP AND VOTE. AND WE
OUR WAY TO SHOW UP AND VOTE. AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
TO SHOW UP AND VOTE. AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE AN ADMINISTRATION, WHICH WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE AN ADMINISTRATION, WHICH WE ARE FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO HAVE
AN ADMINISTRATION, WHICH WE ARE FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO HAVE RIGHT NOW
ARE FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO HAVE RIGHT NOW WITH PRESIDENT BIDEN AND HIS
RIGHT NOW WITH PRESIDENT BIDEN AND HIS ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO ARE GOING
WITH PRESIDENT BIDEN AND HIS ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO ARE GOING TO FIGHT THOSE LAWS STATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO ARE GOING TO FIGHT THOSE LAWS STATE BY STATE
TO FIGHT THOSE LAWS STATE BY STATE STATE BY STATE.
BY STATE STATE BY STATE. IF THEY DEEM THEM TO BE
STATE BY STATE. IF THEY DEEM THEM TO BE UNCONSTITUTIONAL, AS MANY OF
IF THEY DEEM THEM TO BE UNCONSTITUTIONAL, AS MANY OF THEM ARE.
UNCONSTITUTIONAL, AS MANY OF THEM ARE. I WANT TO TURN NOW TO THE
THEM ARE. I WANT TO TURN NOW TO THE INSURRECTION ON JANUARY
I WANT TO TURN NOW TO THE INSURRECTION ON JANUARY 6. PRESIDENT, OBAMA SPOKE AT
INSURRECTION ON JANUARY 6. PRESIDENT, OBAMA SPOKE AT AN EVENT TODAY ABOUT
6. PRESIDENT, OBAMA SPOKE AT AN EVENT TODAY ABOUT THAT THE ATTACK ON THE CAPITAL
AN EVENT TODAY ABOUT THAT THE ATTACK ON THE CAPITAL AND THE POTENTIAL FOR A
THAT THE ATTACK ON THE CAPITAL AND THE POTENTIAL FOR A REPEAT. SO LET‘S TAKE A
AND THE POTENTIAL FOR A REPEAT. SO LET‘S TAKE A LISTEN.
REPEAT. SO LET‘S TAKE A LISTEN. THE GUARDRAILS I THOUGHT WERE
LISTEN. THE GUARDRAILS I THOUGHT WERE IN PLACE AROUND
THE GUARDRAILS I THOUGHT WERE IN PLACE AROUND MANY OF OUR DEMOCRATIC
IN PLACE AROUND MANY OF OUR DEMOCRATIC INSTITUTIONS.
MANY OF OUR DEMOCRATIC INSTITUTIONS. REALLY DEPEND ON
INSTITUTIONS. REALLY DEPEND ON THE TWO PARTIES
REALLY DEPEND ON THE TWO PARTIES AGREEING TO THOSE GROUND RULES
THE TWO PARTIES AGREEING TO THOSE GROUND RULES THOSE GUARDRAILS, AND THAT ONE
AGREEING TO THOSE GROUND RULES THOSE GUARDRAILS, AND THAT ONE OF THEM RIGHT NOW
THOSE GUARDRAILS, AND THAT ONE OF THEM RIGHT NOW DOESN‘T SEEM AS COMMITTED TO
OF THEM RIGHT NOW DOESN‘T SEEM AS COMMITTED TO THEM
DOESN‘T SEEM AS COMMITTED TO THEM AS
THEM AS IN PREVIOUS GENERATIONS,
AS IN PREVIOUS GENERATIONS, THAT WORRIES ME
IN PREVIOUS GENERATIONS, THAT WORRIES ME AND I THINK WE SHOULD ALL BE
THAT WORRIES ME AND I THINK WE SHOULD ALL BE WORRIED.
AND I THINK WE SHOULD ALL BE WORRIED. I MEAN, I THINK THERE‘S SORT
WORRIED. I MEAN, I THINK THERE‘S SORT OF PROVERBIAL GUARDRAILS AND
I MEAN, I THINK THERE‘S SORT OF PROVERBIAL GUARDRAILS AND REAL GARDEN PILLS THAT WE
OF PROVERBIAL GUARDRAILS AND REAL GARDEN PILLS THAT WE ALL WERE SURPRISED
REAL GARDEN PILLS THAT WE ALL WERE SURPRISED WEREN‘T AS FIRM AS WE THOUGHT,
ALL WERE SURPRISED WEREN‘T AS FIRM AS WE THOUGHT, AT THIS RATE HOW MUCH
WEREN‘T AS FIRM AS WE THOUGHT, AT THIS RATE HOW MUCH DEMOCRACY
AT THIS RATE HOW MUCH DEMOCRACY IS AT RISK.
DEMOCRACY IS AT RISK. HOW MUCH IS DEMOCRACY AT
IS AT RISK. HOW MUCH IS DEMOCRACY AT RISKS? I‘M SORRY.
HOW MUCH IS DEMOCRACY AT RISKS? I‘M SORRY. DOOLEY. I THINK I THINK WE ARE
RISKS? I‘M SORRY. DOOLEY. I THINK I THINK WE ARE AT A PRECIPICE HERE.
DOOLEY. I THINK I THINK WE ARE AT A PRECIPICE HERE. WHEN
AT A PRECIPICE HERE. WHEN THE SITTING PRESIDENT OF THE
WHEN THE SITTING PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
THE SITTING PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES TELLS PEOPLE THAT THE ELECTION
UNITED STATES TELLS PEOPLE THAT THE ELECTION WAS UNFAIR, EVEN THOUGH HIS
TELLS PEOPLE THAT THE ELECTION WAS UNFAIR, EVEN THOUGH HIS OWN ADMINISTRATION
WAS UNFAIR, EVEN THOUGH HIS OWN ADMINISTRATION AND THE FBI TO HOMELAND
OWN ADMINISTRATION AND THE FBI TO HOMELAND SECURITY
AND THE FBI TO HOMELAND SECURITY TO THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
SECURITY TO THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TELLS HIM, THAT‘S NOT TRUE.
TO THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TELLS HIM, THAT‘S NOT TRUE. HE PERPETUATES THIS
TELLS HIM, THAT‘S NOT TRUE. HE PERPETUATES THIS FARCE THAT. IT WAS A
HE PERPETUATES THIS FARCE THAT. IT WAS A THAT IT WAS AN ELECTION THAT
FARCE THAT. IT WAS A THAT IT WAS AN ELECTION THAT WAS STOLEN FROM HIM
THAT IT WAS AN ELECTION THAT WAS STOLEN FROM HIM WHEN HE TELLS HIS SUPPORTERS
WAS STOLEN FROM HIM WHEN HE TELLS HIS SUPPORTERS THAT THEY SHOULD TAKE TO THE
WHEN HE TELLS HIS SUPPORTERS THAT THEY SHOULD TAKE TO THE STREETS AND GO AND FIGHT.
THAT THEY SHOULD TAKE TO THE STREETS AND GO AND FIGHT. TO DEFEND HIS PRESIDENCY.
STREETS AND GO AND FIGHT. TO DEFEND HIS PRESIDENCY. WHICH HE LOST.
TO DEFEND HIS PRESIDENCY. WHICH HE LOST. AND THEY RESPOND.
WHICH HE LOST. AND THEY RESPOND. IN KIND AND
AND THEY RESPOND. IN KIND AND STORMED THE CAPITAL
IN KIND AND STORMED THE CAPITAL AND THEN THE
STORMED THE CAPITAL AND THEN THE REPUBLICANS DECIDE THAT WE
AND THEN THE REPUBLICANS DECIDE THAT WE SHOULDN‘T INVESTIGATE, WHAT
REPUBLICANS DECIDE THAT WE SHOULDN‘T INVESTIGATE, WHAT HAPPENED AND FIND OUT WHO WAS
SHOULDN‘T INVESTIGATE, WHAT HAPPENED AND FIND OUT WHO WAS BEHIND IT AND WE SEE
HAPPENED AND FIND OUT WHO WAS BEHIND IT AND WE SEE EVIDENCE THAT SOME OF THEM
BEHIND IT AND WE SEE EVIDENCE THAT SOME OF THEM WERE COMPLICIT
EVIDENCE THAT SOME OF THEM WERE COMPLICIT IN THAT ATTACK
WERE COMPLICIT IN THAT ATTACK AND THE VERY ONES WHO SAID,
IN THAT ATTACK AND THE VERY ONES WHO SAID, WELL, IT WAS NOTHING OTHER
AND THE VERY ONES WHO SAID, WELL, IT WAS NOTHING OTHER THAN AN ORDINARY
WELL, IT WAS NOTHING OTHER THAN AN ORDINARY TOUR. WE SEE PHOTOGRAPHS OF
THAN AN ORDINARY TOUR. WE SEE PHOTOGRAPHS OF THEM BARRICADED IN TRYING TO
TOUR. WE SEE PHOTOGRAPHS OF THEM BARRICADED IN TRYING TO PROTECT THEMSELVES FROM
THEM BARRICADED IN TRYING TO PROTECT THEMSELVES FROM THIS ONSLAUGHT. IF
PROTECT THEMSELVES FROM THIS ONSLAUGHT. IF THAT SCENE HAPPENED IN ANY
THIS ONSLAUGHT. IF THAT SCENE HAPPENED IN ANY OTHER COUNTRY
THAT SCENE HAPPENED IN ANY OTHER COUNTRY AROUND THE WORLD,
OTHER COUNTRY AROUND THE WORLD, THE UNITED STATES WOULD BE THE
AROUND THE WORLD, THE UNITED STATES WOULD BE THE FIRST APPOINTED FINGER AND SAY
THE UNITED STATES WOULD BE THE FIRST APPOINTED FINGER AND SAY THAT IS A THREAT TO DEMOCRACY.
FIRST APPOINTED FINGER AND SAY THAT IS A THREAT TO DEMOCRACY. AND THE
THAT IS A THREAT TO DEMOCRACY. AND THE REPUBLICANS WHO CONDONE THAT
AND THE REPUBLICANS WHO CONDONE THAT HAVE TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
REPUBLICANS WHO CONDONE THAT HAVE TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE. AND SO WE NEED TO GET TO THE
HAVE TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE. AND SO WE NEED TO GET TO THE FACTS, WE HAVE TO HAVE
AND SO WE NEED TO GET TO THE FACTS, WE HAVE TO HAVE TRANSPARENCY WITH THE AMERICAN
FACTS, WE HAVE TO HAVE TRANSPARENCY WITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THOSE GUARDRAILS
TRANSPARENCY WITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THOSE GUARDRAILS ARE WHAT PROTECTS OUR
PEOPLE AND THOSE GUARDRAILS ARE WHAT PROTECTS OUR DEMOCRACY. AND SO, IF WE LET
ARE WHAT PROTECTS OUR DEMOCRACY. AND SO, IF WE LET THEM JUST FALL BY THE WAYSIDE,
DEMOCRACY. AND SO, IF WE LET THEM JUST FALL BY THE WAYSIDE, THEN WHO ARE WE?
THEM JUST FALL BY THE WAYSIDE, THEN WHO ARE WE? WHO ARE WE
THEN WHO ARE WE? WHO ARE WE WE
WHO ARE WE WE IT‘S A GOOD QUESTION
WE IT‘S A GOOD QUESTION THAT I THINK FOLKS SHOULD
IT‘S A GOOD QUESTION THAT I THINK FOLKS SHOULD MARINATE ON A LITTLE BIT
THAT I THINK FOLKS SHOULD MARINATE ON A LITTLE BIT VALERIE. JARED, THANK YOU. AS
MARINATE ON A LITTLE BIT VALERIE. JARED, THANK YOU. AS ALWAYS FOR TAKING THE TIME TO
VALERIE. JARED, THANK YOU. AS ALWAYS FOR TAKING THE TIME TO JOIN ME TODAY. AND PLEASE STAY